a new class-action lawsuit accuses
Google of pay discrimination against
women three women who used to work for
Google filed the suit yesterday they
claimed the tech giant is quote paying
female employees less than male
employees with similar skills experience
and duties google responds with this we
disagree with the central allegations
and we have extensive systems in place
to ensure that we pay fairly CBS News
contributor that's Nicholas Thompson is
editor in chief of Wired magazine he's
in San Francisco Nick good morning to
you good morning listen one of the
plaintiffs attorneys is for the is
saying about Google its treatment of
female employees has not entered the
21st century so a couple of questions do
you think that's a feeling about Google
in Silicon Valley and how big a deal is
this lawsuit how significant I think it
is something that a lot of people in
Silicon Valley feel both about Google
and about a lot of the other tech
companies there are a whole bunch of
things happening right now in Silicon
Valley they're accusations of gender
paid discrimination
they're accusations of sexual harassment
their general accusations that it is
very hard to be a woman in Silicon
Valley and Silicon Valley meanwhile at
this moment is such a crucial part of
the American economy so it's a big big
deal this particularly suit itself is
also a big deal there are it is covers
all women who worked at Google over the
last four years so if Google loses
that's a big payout even if they don't
lose and it settles it's gonna be a
continuing public perception problem for
google and may make it harder for them
to attract and retain qualified women
who they certainly need yeah cuz
Google's employee demographics show that
women make up only about 20% of its tech
positions what kind of changes can a
lawsuit like this make inside Google
well if Google determines that the
lawsuit is is fair and is accurate they
can change their hiring practices they
can say okay so why is it that we end up
even if it's unconscious why do we put
women on career tracks that don't go as
far why do we make as the lawsuit
alleges make more of them kind of go
into front-end engineering and not
back-end engineering which ends up being
paid more what exactly are we doing
Google has thought about these things so
in their HR and pay practices which is
something they say in response the
don't tell the people determining
someone's salary the gender of the
person so they've actually made
conscious steps to try to alleviate this
problem but clearly based on the data
that we've seen and based on the
allegations in this lawsuit they have
not done enough all right Nick Thompson
joining us from San Francisco Nick thank
you very much thank you